let me just read the news first the u.s
sun reports
tense clash china accuses u.s of
slaughtering black people
and says americans have little faith in
democracy as talk tensions flare
they say the two nations met face to
face in anchorage alaska on thursday
evening
for the first time since president joe
biden took office but any hopes that
bilateral relations could be reset after
years of trade wars
and tensions over cyber security during
trump's presidency were quickly stamped
out
u.s secretary of state anthony anthony
blinken and national security adviser
jake sullivan
opened uh opening the meeting by
referring to concerns over beijing's
human rights record
china's top foreign affairs official
yang jiechi thunderously responded
by accusing the us of its own human
rights violations saying
we hope the u.s will do better on human
rights yang said during a 50-minute
speech
the fact is that there are many problems
in the u.s regarding human rights which
is emitted by the u.s itself
yang added that human rights issues in
the u.s just racism were deep seated
they did not just emerge over the past
four years such as black lives matter
this is really annoying to me because
the the narrative for the most part from
black lives matter is
over hyped exaggerated and just i'm
gonna say it not true
i don't know if uh you i think you you
may have seen this ian but did you see
the the poll
where they asked liberals and
conservatives
how many innocent you know or how many
black people were killed by police in
2019
and liberals said over a thousand and
the actual number is 27.
so what's happening is what yeah we have
this median narrative
this big lie where they keep saying
these things over and over again
and you get these people who genuinely
believe that cops are going around
hunting down black people if i thought
that was true
i'd be out there with black lives matter
every single day but we know it's not
true
any death caused by the cops it's it's a
tragedy
either it you know the cop was defending
himself it's still a tragedy
or the cop was committing a crime
especially a tragedy
now china is exploiting this our own
media is tearing our country apart
in my opinion and now china's accusing
us of being weak
yeah it's it's kind of interesting you
know china obviously can't look in the
mirror and never
call out their own sins for example
obviously just how
oppressive they are to their own people
the re-education camps of uyghurs
the lack you know basically the the hong
kong and
threatening their autonomy uh and
jailing basically any political
dissident
so they have no obviously no moral
standing on this issue
i just find it hilarious that they think
that
the us government is sanctioning like
basically all this
terrorism against uh one you know
racial demographic i don't think they
they believe it no i mean like they
i mean but they're accusing us of this i
think i think
it's really interesting in previous
administrations would china have
stood up so brazenly and insulted
degraded the united states to their
faces
nope the iron wasn't hot enough but but
you know what i think i mean if you
remember under the obama administration
and the the plane situation the plane
uh confrontation and they basically made
them
almost i think it was like they wouldn't
let them land or get off the plane they
basically had to
oh wow yeah this is so this is how this
happened on the obama administration i
don't know if this is something
that you know it was an almost an
international incident that had to get
stamped out quickly
because china they ramped up the
aggression against uh
you know foreign diplomats or i guess
u.s diplomats in this case
and then you have the whole anal swabs
thing oh yeah
u.s diplomats entering the country and
they had to get the coveted test well so
we'll jump to that in a second but the
point i want to make is
as the tensions escalate as u.s
uh power wanes internationally and and
other countries are losing confidence in
whether or not the united states could
even defend a place like taiwan or the
south china sea
china is getting more and more brazen
they know the narrative is not true
they don't care they're putting on a
show for the people of the world to say
we're not scared of america anymore and
we're going to stand up
and we're going to use their own
fracturing of their of their culture
against them
that's what's happening now as for the
the butt swabs thing which was like a
huge story
i think it's fair to say if donald trump
was president that would not have
happened
yeah that's fair to say but i also and
we were talking about this i don't think
under the trump administration they
would sen they willingly
they would willingly send out a group of
diplomats to
china in the middle of a trade war right
and basically subject themselves to
something like this
i mean during the trade war negotiations
for the first trade deal that they
uh agreed to all the negotiations
happened in washington dc literally
across the from the
eisenhower executive office building
which is the white house um
but they're they're sending diplomats to
china for what routine work
i mean i don't know i mean we had an
ambassador to the we had the u.s
ambassador to china
and we still have diplomatic relations
with them but
you know there is no reason
to subject our own diplomats to that
it's
it's just an embarrassment it's amazing
for those that aren't familiar uh us
diplomats were
forcefully anal swabbed by china yeah
and i think that's another another sign
of just
attempting to humiliate the united
states for forceful swabbing of the bums
of american personnel
and they're basically look at this
meeting
it was 15 minutes of of the chinese
you know officials yelling at america
and the americans just sat there and
took it
saber-rattling uh so i just wanted to
point out
that the whole confrontation with the
obama administration
uh so the u.s military always sends out
a set of rolling air stairs
on every single uh presidential trip
and so they have to seek chinese
approval to use the equipment
and when president obama arrived in
china
the chinese reversed their position they
wouldn't let him get off the plane wow
but was was obama supposed to be there
yeah it was i think it was actually a
supposed to be a official presidential
visit
to me so the president so this wouldn't
have happened under trump
is that what do you think it's fair to
say well it didn't happen under trump
because when he went to china
he got like a huge welcoming uh ceremony
i
mean
i mean i people don't people remember
obviously his
his uh meeting with kim jong-un and uh
in vietnam
uh in singapore um i think it was just
singapore they had at least two meetings
if i'm not mistaken um but when he went
to china
there was a huge ceremony there was a
huge like
celebration of the u.s president going
to china
and if you remember correctly president
xi
and president trump actually had like
deep affection for one another
but at the same time trump was telling
everybody here in the united states like
obviously we're going to be implementing
all these tariffs on china
uh a lot of tough talk but and this is
where he gets the criticism for being
you know cozying up to authoritarians
because of
how he approaches them now his
actual rhetoric is different from the
actual policy because the policy was
good
even if the rhetoric didn't match it and
that's i think that's what people
constantly get at trump for
but he was particularly strong on china
and biden is particularly weak on china
could it have been
that fanfare in that celebration was
because they were scared of trump
trump that's possible look man trump is
an erratic hey
hey we're still number one baby i i look
at it like this
even people like even trump supporters
recognize that trump is kind of
you know erratic i guess is the right
way to put it meaning like
he just says do it get it done come it
come pops into his head he says do it
so if he gets mad on a whim he could be
like shut it down no no deal for you
so china knows these this trade war is
on yeah the tariffs are are a legit
problem for them
so they start kissing us yeah i think
the chinese communist party is a glass
cannon
in in that they're very fragile from
what i've been discerning from our
guests in the last few weeks
they're they're on the verge of collapse
but they don't want to show it and if
they sense weakness they're going to go
and bite it because they can hit
hard from a distance but if if they get
attacked they got a real problem
and biden is not an attacker i i don't i
don't physically
i don't think the chinese communist
party is particularly weak i think
they're still
on the rise i think it is what's
changing though is the
sort of the the
what's the best word i could probably
put it on um
sort of the image the the there was a
fallacy that russia was somehow the most
dangerous country in the world and that
was our geopolitical
foe and threat and they hijacked an
election and basically installed trump
as
you know putin's you know lap dog like
you know as crazy as the
you know that that blue a non-talk um
but then everybody just ignored china
and now we're realizing everything
that's happening there you have the
weaker re-education camps you have
uh hong kong autonomy withering away you
have the
oppression of basically everyone and
their political dissidence
they have the belt and road initiative
uh which boss basically it
mortgages the future of basically every
single country abroad
uh that china does business with
particularly in africa
they build up their infrastructure in
exchange for
uh so like they'll give say a country
like you know mozambique or
or you know name your country in africa
uh you know billion dollar loans
but we get to control your ports it
sounds they have to pay back that loan
sounds like they're just placing the imf
yeah that's the economic hitman strategy
right
and so they get all this economic
control over these countries
and they get to gain access to their
valuable resources
whatever mining uh whatever you know
grain
you name it farming and uh
yeah they just consolidate that power
and
the reason why they're still on the come
up is and and this obviously is tied
into
the political oppression is that when
you only have one single thought
you can get a lot more done i think bill
maher was talking about it as well as
tucker carlson
interestingly enough in the same week
about how china is particularly strong
in their military
because they just focus on the job and
just get it done
and i think bill maher's criticism in
particular wasn't praiseworthy of of the
chinese communist party but really
highlighting how
um they because they're so authoritarian
they can get more done
and we are so democratic we can get
nothing done
and it's just democratic is one way to
put it thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you